un accroc qui assure donc vouloir des
solutions concrètes voir des solutions
concrètes même à la crise ukrainienne
est ce vraiment le cas place à notre
décryptage
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir sur
ce plateau emmanuel dupuy président de
l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe bonsoir mnl dupuis merci d'être
avec nous à nos côtés bruno trotsky
historien spécialiste de la russie et
des pays de l'est bonsoir merci
également de nous accompagner ce soir la
conférence de presse éclair 1 vient de
s'achever emmanuel dupuis apologue
allemagne france je découvre en même
temps le contenu dans sa durée environ
montre en main dix minutes nous allons
continuer à agir dans des objectifs
simples défendre les principes qui ont
fait notre europe ces trente dernières
années trouver des voies et des moyens
d'engager
les jeunes les moyens vers un pardon
parce qu'on me l'a écrit c'est pas
évident à lire les moyens importants
vers la russie pour différents formats
premier objectif éviter la guerre le
deuxième consolider et défendre à chaque
instant l'unité des européens et des
alliés très tourné sur l'europe l'unité
de l'europe est ce qu'on parle également
des gages qu'on pourrait donner à la
russie en tout cas ce que la durci aussi
demande en termes de garanties de
sécurité déjà vous avez raison de
mentionner le symbole de la durée la
rencontre entre valimir poutine et même
macron a été singulièrement longue en
bilatéral mais la conférence de presse a
été dense la deuxième conférence de
presse à kiev entre volodymyr zemlinsky
et le président et macron a été beaucoup
plus courte il a d'ailleurs été question
aussi de relations bilatérales
pratiquement autant que de la question
des tensions d'ailleurs le président
volodymyr rosinski a botté en touche
plusieurs fois quand est il a été
interrogé sur ce qu'il attendait de la
désescalade et puis dix minutes comme
vous l'évoquez avec le président andres
duda et le chancelier olaf scholz a
néanmoins vous avez mentionné en fait le
paradoxe de du phrasé ou du narratif des
malades macron 30 ans c'est pas l'union
européenne ces lois c est en fait on
joue à constamment sur le paradoxe on
donnerait l'impression que c'était même
à contre présent du conseil de l'union
européenne qui a parlé avec lumières
coutume c'est oublier un peu vite que
olaf scholz a parlé à joe biden en tant
que président du g7 et que le processus
de normandie le format de normandie le
processus de minsk le protocole de mise
puisque c'est comme ça qu'ils
s'appellent depuis 2014 ainsi que les
rencontres
fadri latéral qui ont été évoqués
s'inscrivent tous dans le lot et c'est
donc en fait il faut avoir à l'esprit
que le président avait d'ailleurs
routine le président aimé le maquereau
le président ukrainien est bien
évidemment de chance également et le
président polonais parle de la même
chose mais en ne mettant pas les mêmes
organisations le président et même à
kron a donné l'impression qu'il parlait
au nom des 30 pays membres de l'otan il
me semble que le secrétaire général
viennent stoltenberg n'a pas du tout les
mêmes doléances vis-à-vis de moscou
d'ailleurs ça a été évoqué par dimitri
peskov il ya quelques instants donc je
crois qu'on est encore dans ce paradoxe
mais en tout cas larchitecture de spe et
de sécurité de confiance le
rétablissement de la confiance il a été
beaucoup question de confiance durant
ces dernières heures nous ramène à la
conférence d'helsinki pour ne pas dire à
un processus qui s'appelle au processus
de corfou en 2009 où déjà à l'époque
dimitri medvedev président de la russie
avait appelé à ce qu'on traite des
questions de sécurité entre européens au
niveau de l'essieu ans ne mélangeons pas
l'agenda politique de l'union européenne
l'agenda sécuritaire euro-atlantique de
l'otan et brno ce qui est même
diagnostic déjà pour commencer un
comment sont dans l'ordre sur cette
conférence de presse assez clair dix
minutes entre les les trois des gens
certaines sera suivie de conversations
privées mais ça dit quelque chose cette
conférence est claire oui très
certainement bien sûr que si
si on a eu une très longue conférence
uta rencontre entre mac routine c'est
parce que c'était là où l'enjeu se se
déroule est
venu aujourd'hui la conférence très très
courte elle montre en fait que
préparent les réponses à donner à la
russie et que il n'y a pas pour le
moment encore grand chose à dire je
dirais que l'essentiel en fait c'est la
position de l'allemagne pourquoi parce
que
l'allemagne est assez facilement accusé
d'être pro russe alors que à cause du
gazoduc nord stream biensur et aussi à
cause de beaucoup d'autres choses
puisque l'allemagne est une puissance
industrielle qui a beaucoup d'intérêt
développer des relations à l'est et en
particulier dans le rallye est encore en
particulier avec la russie est donc
toute l'attention qu'on a aujourd'hui
largement
provoquée entre autres pour essayer
d'éloigner l'allemagne de la russie et
donc c'est important de voir que on a
envoyé si je veux dire l'union
européenne les européens auront plus ou
moins accepté ce que ce soit prise en
macro qui représente l'europe à moscou
pendant que si je veux dire le
chancelier allemand allait calmer les
américains à washington
justement washington ça veut dire tout
de même un but puis tu es un nouvel axe
dans la négociation avant on avait la
russie face aux états unis un axe
américano européen désormais je suis
plus dubitatif que vous premièrement ce
week-end
important un petit peu de modération le
président américain a été très
comminatoire vis-à-vis du chancellier
olaf scholz qui lui-même a botté en
touche le président américain je crois
en parle français paraphrasant ses mots
a dit nous trouverons un moyen de vous
empêcher que nord stream 2 ce test
fonctionne et le pré chance et les
allemands à dix on trouvera les moyens
d'agir en concertation il n'y a pas du
tout validé les propos du président
américain je répète que le chancelier
allemand et président du g7
le président français et président du
conseil de l'union européenne il n'y a
pas forcément une adéquation parfaite
sur beaucoup de sujets mon collègue
évoqué l'eurasie la manière de traiter
la relation avec la chine l'allemagne
est le premier partenaire économique de
la chine sur le continent européen ce
qui n'est pas le cas de la france
d'autant plus que la france avec la
décision de décrire ce qu'est classique
à son enseignante comme un génocide
c'est un petit peu éloigné
singulièrement c'est j'ose dire de pékin
deuxième élément de réflexion
le président polonais andrzej joue des
duda est un populiste je ne suis pas
certain que une forme d' escalade
l'arrangent d'autant plus qu'il est
voisin de la biélorussie comme de la
russie et que si il y avait une forme et
puis je rappelle que l'enclavé de
kaliningrad limitrophe de la pologne
également donc je suis pas certain non
plus que le président polonais
s'attendrait à une position militaire
s'attendrait à un déplacement de troupes
américaines le président trompe vous les
déplacez dix mille hommes en pologne on
en est pas à cette configuration donc je
crois qu'on est évidemment dans une
logique d désescalade je dirais pas
qu'ils aient un front au ralenti par
contre il ya une volonté de la part de
l'europe de l'union européenne en tout
cas des pays européens de l'otan
d'agir différemment vis-à-vis de
l'avenir poutine
la chancellière angela merkel le
président macron en juin dernier avait
tenté un dernier baroud d'honneur c'est
j'ose dire en essayant d'engager les 27
dans un dialogue avec moscou 25 les 25
autres pays n'avait pas validé cette
approche force est de constater que dans
la situation critique dans lequel nous
nous trouvons
je crois qu'on va y arriver
progressivement en tout cas emmanuel
macron lui est plutôt optimiste
écoutez ce qu'il a dit à kiev un peu
plus tôt dans la journée
je crois pour ma part il y a des
solutions
pratique qui nous permettront d'analyser
nous avons eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
ensemble j'ai eu l'occasion de l'évoquer
également avec le président poutine
comme je lé fais avec mes partenaires
européens et plusieurs de noëlle renaude
roski c'est sûr que le président
français se montrent plutôt optimistes
c'est tout à son avantage
d'ailleurs y compris sur la scène
intérieure il n'empêche à moscou un
petit peu de tempérer cet enthousiasme
aujourd'hui en disant très bien il ya
une ouverture m'enfin pour le moment
les occidentaux n'ont pas vraiment
répondu à nos demandes de sécurité à nos
exigences entre guillemets ça il faut
aussi obtenir quoi on peut être ce soir
y allons bien sûr que la russie a très
fermement rappelé ses exigences et il
faut évidemment prendre en compte que du
point de vue russe la russie a reculé
depuis trente ans et que là aujourd'hui
on a une espèce de niet pour parler plus
loin que sur ce plan là tu la russie est
ferme et risque de le rester donc ça
c'est très clair mais je dirais que
l'optimisme du président maquereau en
ukraine y laissant des pieds aussi au
fait que en dépit des
apparences le président ukrainien lui
même au coût modéré ces existences
depuis un certain temps il faut se
rappeler que la conversation qu'il a eue
avec le président paille d'un récemment
ne s'est pas bien terminé puisque en
fait grosso modo anaïs qui demandait ce
que les américains soient moins
menaçants
parce que hélas la tension aujourd'hui
menace directement l'ukraine n'ont pas
seulement d'une guerre parce que ça
apparemment il n'en est pas question
même si on en parle beaucoup mais c'est
la situation économique de l'ukraine qui
est catastrophique parce que
les tensions actuelles ont fait que la
monnaie ukrainienne s'était faudrait et
que les grands oligarques d'ukrainiens
commencent à trouver que le coût de
cette crise
on sait que en ukraine ce sont les
oligarques qui gouverne et non pas les
institutions officielles d'ailleurs je
pense que dans la conférence de presse
du président macro il ya eu une petite
allusion à cela lorsqu'il a parlé de la
démocratisation d'ukraine il faut aussi
rappeler que quand il était à moscou
poutine lui avait mentionné quelques cas
des droits de l'homme violés en ukraine
donc tout cela évidemment a sans doute
fait que le président maquereau a
rappelé à ses les skis que la l'ukraine
avancée certes selon lui mais peut-être
pas exactement au rythme voulu et en
même temps l'ukraine a absolument besoin
de paix pour pouvoir restaurer son
économie qui est en mauvaise posture
de cela si l'ukraine elle même commence
un peu se retirer de la stratégie de la
tension finalement il ne reste que les
états unis pourraient être très ferme à
l'égard de la russie ce qui fait quand
même assez peu en dépit du fait que
c'est évidemment la première puissance
mondiale et ce n'est plus la plaisance
unipolaire qu'on a connu il ya une
trentaine d'années
je voudrais compléter ce qu'a dit mon
collègue il a été d'ailleurs assez drôle
d'entendre le vote président vladimir
poutine offrir l'asile politique aux
deux anciens président loukachenko et
prochain qu en évoquant la question des
droits de l'homme comme ça a été
justement mentionné c'est d'ailleurs le
président macro qui lui même a parlé de
démocratisation et puis il faut avoir
aussi à l'esprit que le président
volodymyr synesci à une majorité un peu
fragile à la rada et que évidemment il a
besoin aussi
donner l'impression qu'il est dans la
désescalade
la radicalisation est une vue que nous
aimerions avoir sur l'ukraine mais
l'ukraine ce ne se résume pas qu'à kiev
il ya des régions qui ont plus ou moins
des approches différentes de la entre la
périphérie est la capitale et puis après
il ya un autre élément effectivement à
dimension économique est déterminante
parce que les principaux acteurs ces
dernières années dans les
investissements les plus structurants
pour l'ukraine dans l'économie numérique
dans le spatial c'est ni les pays de
l'union européenne et la russie mais la
chine et donc d'une certaine façon tout
le monde a intérêt à ce qu'on aille pas
versé désescalade la russie le président
zielinski l'union européenne évidemment
les bailleurs de fonds qui sont plutôt
orientaux qui dernier point c'était j'ai
écouté les trois conférences de presse
donc celle à moscou c'est là qu'est fsl
donc en pologne enfin oui à berlin
pardon avec le président polonais j'ai
effectivement constaté que le président
céline ce qui lui-même se trouve dans
une la quadrature du cercle alors qu'il
ya quelques heures il réfuté ce que
contenait le protocole de minsk or tout
le monde veut le président poutine l'a
dit le président macron l'a redit trois
fois qu'on soit dans cette logique des
négociations le président éric zéni ce
qui risque d'avoir beaucoup à convaincre
à kiev et par rapport à cette question
est pourtant bruno ganz qui a c'est le
mode f1 avant de se rendre à moscou et
emmanuel macron a rappelé qu' une grande
partie de la solution et barel était
justement entre les mains du président
zine ce qui
traînait ses soeurs est tout à fait
juste effectivement j'ai laisse qui joue
un rôle clé et en même temps il n'a pas
la force nécessaire pour pouvoir imposer
sans négocier fortement sa politique
tant sur le plan international que sur
le plan intérieur donc il est dans une
position extrêmement fragile et en même
temps c'est finalement lui qui
est au centre de l'attention et donc
effectivement
son évolution est intéressante alors on
voit évidemment en ukraine des forces
d'opposition pu nationaliste essayer de
faire monter la pression mais
la menace qui d'un nouveau maille dame
que cette opposition essaie de faire de
te montrer me semble assez irréaliste
dans la mesure où l'ukraine pour lui
ceci était très fatigué merci bonne
adresse qui merci emmanuel dupuis
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce décryptage
ce soir merci à vous